[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to marvel have just dropped some
amazing news on guardians of the galaxy
three that looks set to shake up the MCU
in several ways this comes in the form
of beta ray bill news outlive we got
this covered broke the story yesterday
and if you're a huge Thor fan and this
is definitely the kind of news that
you've been hoping for whilst the
background of Thor has been pretty
heavily covered in the MCU films fan
favorite be array has always been
missing from the movies but guardians 3
is said to rectify this the character
was originally meant to cameo in
Ragnarok however at the time Marvel
Studios had Kevin Feige said that his
brief appearance was cut because it
didn't do him justice bogey is said to
have stated if you can't do it justice
do it later and it looks like guardians
3 is the perfect time for this for those
who don't know builds life force and
consciousness were transferred by
scientists of his race into a body of an
alien carnivorous feast that had been
Bionic Lea restructured into a cyborg
the horse looking creature has been
mounted on a similar costume to Thor and
is also wielded Stormbreaker in the
comics he possesses vast superhuman
strength speed stamina and durability
and a highly extended lifespan not only
is he one of the best hand-to-hand
buyers in the MCU he's also able to go
toe-to-toe with Thor which makes him a
great character to bring into the
universe now from here or now it's full
spoilers ahead for Avengers and game so
if you haven't seen it yet then I highly
suggest that you turn off now but at the
end of that film we saw Thor leaving new
Asgard with the guardians of the galaxy
and whilst we never got confirmation
that the character would be in their
next outing for me this pretty much
confirms it there's really no other
reason to bring Bill into the film if
Thor isn't with them and I'm so hyped
that the characters will now be part of
the same movie I can see Bill probably
starting off as a villain before joining
the group and maybe even becoming a
close ally of Thor's similar to Korg
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this breaking news and if you're
excited to see the character makers big
MCU debut comment below and let me know
and if you want to see more Marvel
breakdowns then make sure you check out
my Avengers endgame playlist which will
be linked at the end it covers all the
big questions like how the paradoxes and
the film's work and how black widows
death can be reversed so it's definitely
worth checking out this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe but thanks again for taking
the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]